What if the biggest threat to your bank
account is not what you think it is?
It's not inflation. It's not the stock
market. It's a 200 years old lie. A
single stubborn myth from the 19th
century that political leaders are still
using today to sell you on trade wars.
And no, this isn't some conspiracy
theory. It's a well doumented political
playbook. Today, we're pulling back the
curtains to show you how this one idea
is still justifying destructive economic
policies that hurt you, your country,
and the global economy. It seems like
everywhere you look, walls are going up.
We are living in an age of escalating
trade wars. Just in the last few years,
we've seen massive new taxes called
tariffs slept on goods worth billions of
dollars. Everything from cars and steel
to washing machines and solar panels.
The United States and China are locked
into an economic slugfest that has sent
tremors around the entire globe. And the
sales pitch is always the same. We're
told it's about getting tough,
protecting our jobs, and putting America
first. Politicians stand on podiums and
sell us a simple story. To be strong, a
nation has to be self-sufficient. They
frame global trade as a winner take all
brawl where if one country is losing it
means another one is winning. They wrap
these policies in the flag using
patriotism and national security as an
excuse for these tariffs. But let's be
clear about who pays these tariffs. You
do. The consumer. And it works because
it's a powerful narrative. It plays on
our real anxieties about the economy and
our desire for national pride. But this
story, this excuse for building walls is
not something new. It's a carefully
crafted myth with roots stretching back
two centuries. And to see why it's so
dangerous now, we have to understand
where it all started. Let's rewind to
the 19th century, a time of explosive
change. The industrial revolution was
tearing through the world, but not
evenly. Great Britain was the undisputed
factory of the world, while other
countries like a young United States and
the newly formed Germany were struggling
to keep up. For both of these two rising
nations, Great Britain's power was both
impressive and threatening. Enter
Friedrich List, a German economist. List
looked at the popular ideas of free
trade thinkers like Adam Smith and said,
"Hold on a second." He argued that free
trade was a great deal for Britain
because they were already the champions.
For everyone else, he saw it as a trap,
a one-way ticket to become Britain's
permanent economic junior varsity team.
So list cooked up a powerful
counterargument,
one that would become the blueprint for
economic nationalism. He said that for a
nation to build its own industries, it
had to protect its infant industries.
His solution, protective tariffs. By
taxing imported goods, a country makes
foreign goods more expensive. This gives
its own companies the time they need to
grow, to innovate without being
steamrolled by cheaper, more powerful
competitors. He even called it an
a temporary investment in the country's
future. Now, this wasn't a totally new
idea. In the US, figures like Alexander
Hamilton had argued for similar measures
decades earlier. But Hamilton proposed
moderate tariffs paired with subsidies
largely for revenue and to give
fledgling American industries a fair
shot. List was the one who packaged it,
popularized it, and gave it the harder
nationalist framing that swept across
the world. And on the surface, it sounds
pretty smart. What nation doesn't want
to be strong? And just like that, the
myth was born. The belief that trade
barriers are the road to wealth and that
economic isolation is a sign of
strength. It was a story of national
destiny. The only problem is that once
you start looking at the facts, it
starts falling apart. The core promise
of this 200-year-old myth is that
protectionism creates jobs and makes
countries rich. But history tells a much
darker story. The most infamous
cautionary tale is that of the Smooth
Haley Tariff Act of 1930 in the United
States. Passed right after the Great
Depression was sinking its teeth into
the world. The act jacked up tariffs on
over 20,000 imported goods. The goal
they set was to shield American farmers
and businesses from foreign competition.
The result was an absolute catastrophe.
While not the sole cause of the Great
Depression, which was driven by factors
like bank failures and monetary
contraction, the Smooth Haley tariff is
wildly blamed for drastically worsening
it. Instead of protecting the US
economy, the Smooth Haley Act kicked off
a global trade war. Other countries
almost immediately hit back with their
own retalatory tariffs. Global trade
didn't just slow down, it collapsed,
falling by 65% and pushing the world
deeper into economic misery. This didn't
save jobs, it evaporated them. Now, fast
forward to the end of World War II. The
world's leaders, having learned their
lesson from Smooth Haley, tried the
exact opposite. They build a new system
designed to lower trade barriers,
creating institutions like the World
Trade Organization.
This shift towards global cooperation
unleashed an era of unprecedented growth
and prosperity, lifting about 1 billion
people out of extreme poverty since 1990
alone. And guess what? or recent
experiments with trade wars only confirm
what history has taught us. Study after
study on recent trade wars show that the
country imposing the tariff pays the
price. One analysis from the Peterson
Institute for International Economics
found that the steel tariffs cost the US
consumers around $900,000
for every job they created. A Yale study
found that the recent tariff costs the
average American household thousands of
dollars in higher prices. Think about
your phone, your shoes, your car.
Tariffs make all of these things more
expensive. But what about jobs? The
promise of bringing back manufacturing
almost never plays out. A few protected
industries might see tiny gains, but
those are almost always wiped out by job
losses everywhere else. Companies that
need imported parts get slammed by
higher costs. Farmers get locked out of
foreign markets when other countries
retaliate. The net result is almost
always fewer jobs and a weaker economy.
The myth that protectionism is some kind
of magic wand for the economy is just
that, a myth. It sounds great on a
teleprompter, but it crumbles under the
weight of reality. So, if the evidence
is so overwhelmingly clear, why does
this 200-year-old idea still have such a
death grip on politics? The answer is
brutally simple. It works politically.
That is in times of economic anxiety
when people feel left behind. The siren
song of economic nationalism is an
extremely effective way to gain votes.
It offers a simple story with a simple
villain. It is all the fault of unfair
foreign competition. And it offers a
simple solution. Build the wall, tax the
goods. It lets a leader look like the
protector of the little guy, fighting
against shadowy outside forces. This
story works because it taps into real
frustrations. But instead of tackling
the complex domestic problems that are
often the real source of the pain, it
redirects all that anger towards people
in other countries. It's the oldest
political trick in the book,
misdirection.
We see this playbook running on a loop
today. The rhetoric behind Brexit, the
US China trade war, and the rise of
nationalist parties across the globe all
drink from the same poisoned well. They
use these old myths to sell policies
that the evidence says that will hurt
the people that they claim to be
protecting. They sell a fantasy of
strength through isolation. At the exact
same moment that the world has become
more interconnected than ever. Tearing
up those connections doesn't make you
strong. It injects chaos into the
system, raises costs for everyone, and
makes the world a more dangerous place.
So, how do you fight a 200-year-old lie?
With the one thing that manipulative
stories can't stand, the truth. The
solution is to understand the gap
between the political sales pitch and
the economic reality. The reality is
that trade isn't a battle to the death.
Global cooperation has fueled innovation
and has lifted about a billion people
out of poverty since 1990. The reality
is that tariffs are just taxes paid by
the country's own businesses and
consumers, not by foreign nations. And
the reality is that the policies sold
under economic patriotism have a long
and ugly track record of leading to
instability, higher prices, and lost
jobs. When we understand the real
history and the real economics, we take
away the myths power. We can see past
the patriotic slogans and see the
policies for what they really are, a
political game that gamles with our
financial well-being. We can demand
policies based on evidence, not a tired,
destructive myth. History has screamed
the lesson to us time and again.
Building walls leads to decay. Building
bridges leads to prosperity. The choice
is ours, but we have to make it with our
eyes open. If this breakdown made sense
to you, then please share it. The best
way to disarm a harmful myth is to
spread the truth. Subscribe for more
deep dives into the myths that shape our
world. Please let me know in the
comments what myths you think are worth
addressing. Thank you for watching.